similar children PJ the killer ethnic
inequality product organization from the
news city Toma daga stands doctors are
tired this is the main hospital in the
capital mahadji column they've been
fighting kovat 19 since april sleeping
in these wards since then grabbing rest
where they can they're sick but they
carry on some work and when you use
rizzo allocated units new key focus all
of Tony's new stirring opinion mania set
up in one year another aborted promises
I'm a nice patreons raised auroria dr.
animo gaba poster said burnished me at
great no alabaster she was but sure to
show how much camuto fifty health
workers have died just in this one small
region
pneumonia is everywhere or is it just
coded undiagnosed a convenient way to
hide the numbers to cover up how bad
things are here is Basha problem as per
millennium camp in such roads income in
your shop medical $0 is no mister stop
imodium posited camp in South Africa
Watsa foxy jiske prepares to do with the
why him Documenta don't remember yet
nominee Aeneid Khurana gurus in irritate
chilly just irritates ooh
this is how you get your test results in
the capital handed through the railings
by a guard but up in the mountains life
is very different a different ethnicity
from one valley to the next a multitude
of different languages each village
living by its own rules Muslim
traditional and fiercely independent
Zakhar moldova thinks she and her family
had the virus or something like it two
weeks ago and that it's still making its
way through the village II D them is
smaller this year but there are still a
lot of people the extended family it
would be easy for the virus to spread
here
ma divert and her neighbor are
professional mourners their job is
literally to lament the dead
[Music]
and now there are so many to bury so
many to grieve for just in their small
region and how many more are there
across this vast country whose deaths
just aren't being counted Diana Magnay
Sky News Russia